we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p hey this is kind
of a sad voicemail long time adversarial
caller troy york who calls in under fake
names all the time
he left the voi his voicemails are
increasingly disjointed which i know
says a lot for troy yorke um he left one
where it's not even really clear what
point he's making or what he's talking
about it's kind of sad in a way the
trolling has gotten even less coherent
david pakman covered and the fake
numbers
are provided and
manipulated to go after republican
politicians there's no evidence of that
whatsoever plain simple as we see with
his garbage
with the media constantly attacking ron
desantis
in florida remember
florida is reporting numbers under
republican governor ron desantis the
idea that the left is reporting fake
florida numbers to make him look bad
it's the desantis department of health
and desantis appointees that are all
involved in managing the numbers that
are reported this is an incoherent
allegation and uh this is ryan bosworth
i'm calling this is not ryan bosworth
this is troy york of course florida
jacksonville florida and um
if you're so smart why don't you run for
governor in florida or um non-sequitur
completely irrelevant
why don't you run for president in 2024
wasn't born in the u.s not eligible to
be president
what a bizarre and sad downfall of troy
york he's some we haven't played a troy
york voicemail for a while but he's
sometimes leaving three four five
voicemails a day
all under supposedly different names
some of them criticizing me for things i
haven't said i think he's confusing this
show with a different show uh but a sad
state of affairs for troy york hope he
uh hope he does better we've got a great
bonus show for you today
there's a hospital that is saying it
will be denying transplants to
unvaccinated people
in almost all situations can they do
this legally
and what are the details we will discuss
also the u.s federal government
has ordered google to identify
every single person who searched
a sexual assault victim's name address
and telephone number on the internet
they want to do this for investigative
purposes is it legal though we will talk
about it and a third sandy hook parent
has won a defamation lawsuit against
conspiracy theorist alex jones from
infowars we'll talk about the
repercussions and what is going to
happen next all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below